- [Instructor] Have you ever heard someone
call birds living dinosaurs?
You might find that hard to believe.
After all, the city pigeons
that you see wandering
around town don't look
particularly ferocious
like a Tyrannosaurus rex.
But it turns out that
our feathered friends
are actually the direct descendants
of a group of dinosaurs that
lived millions of years ago.
Birds, like every modern species,
have a series of ancestors
stretching back through time.
You can think of these as
the species' grandparents,
great-grandparents,
great-great-grandparents,
and so on, going back
thousands to millions of years.
This series of ancestors
is called a species evolutionary lineage.
And, also like every modern species,
birds have related species
that share a part of their lineage
but then branch off on
their own evolutionary path.
The modern bird lineage stretches way back
to 165 million years ago
to the Jurassic Period.
During this time, iconic dinosaurs,
like the stegosaurus and
brachiosaurus, roamed the Earth,
as well as distant relatives
of our modern-day birds,
like archaeopteryx and anchiornis.
Both archaeopteryx and anchiornis,
among other bird-like dinosaurs,
are considered some of the first birds
based on their long
arms, feathered bodies,
wings and other physical characteristics
that are shared by all birds.
But all birds, both modern-day species
and these earlier bird relatives
that lived in the distant past,
all traced their evolutionary lineage
back to a common ancestor,
which is an ancestral group of organisms
that is shared by one or more lineages.
In other words, any of the
modern birds that you see today,
whether it's a dove or a penguin,
they all evolved from the same
bird-like dinosaur ancestor.
Evolutionary trees can be
used to show the relationships
between different lineages,
like different bird species,
and their common ancestors.
Scientists build evolutionary trees
using various lines of evidence,
such as examining fossils
and body structures
or using DNA to identify shared traits
and other similarities.
The trees serve as models
for studying evolutionary
relationships over time.
So let's take a look at a tree
that scientists built for city pigeons,
also called rock doves,
and their relatives.
What can the tree tell us?
How are doves and these
other species related?
Evolutionary trees are
called trees for a reason.
The evolutionary
relationships between lineages
are represented by branches
showing who is related to whom
and to what degree.
The tips of the branches
of an evolutionary tree
show the modern groups of organisms.
In this case, we have doves,
mesites, and sandgrouse.
They all look different from one another,
but you can see some physical traits,
like their small bills,
that are similar between
all of these birds.
Let's take a look at
this evolutionary tree.
What do you think that
this branch point means?
The branch point, or the
place where branches split,
represents common ancestors
that existed in the past,
among these bird lineages,
from which these modern-day birds evolved.
Mesites and sandgrouse shared
a common ancestor in the past,
about 60 million years ago,
which is represented by a branch point.
But what does this branch
point mean exactly?
Basically, this branch point represents
that at some time in the distant past,
at least 60 million years ago,
a bird species existed, that
wasn't a mesite or sandgrouse,
but it did have some traits found
in both mesites and sandgrouse.
This species was the common ancestor.
At some point, this common
ancestor species split
and gave rise to two
different evolutionary paths
or lineages.
One of those paths gave rise to mesites
and the other led to sandgrouse.
And if we go even further back,
to about 65 million years ago,
we see yet another branch point
representing another common ancestor.
This common ancestor would later
split to form two lineages,
one giving rise to doves
and the other leading
to the common ancestor
of mesites and sandgrouse.
Looking at this evolutionary tree,
we can also learn about
how closely related
different lineages are.
Organisms that share a common ancestor
in the more recent past
are more closely related to one another.
But organisms that share a common ancestor
in the more distant past
are less closely related.
The common ancestor of
mesites and sandgrouse
existed in the more recent past
than the common ancestor of mesites,
sandgrouse and doves.
This means that mesites and sandgrouse
are more closely related to each other
than they are to doves.
Dinosaurs are far in the past now,
but their relatives are still among us.
All the birds that you see every day
evolved from a two-legged
feathered common ancestor
that roamed the Earth
over 165 million years ago with dinosaurs.
So the next time you see
a rock dove flying by
or picking up scraps in a city square,
you're really looking at a dinosaur,
or at least a distant
relative of a dinosaur.